early Monday morning Drake took to
Instagram to send a message about
finding joy in a time of troubles and he
decided to share a photo of his son yeah
so the Sun Adonis is tears old now we've
never seen him before
yeah take a look at the photos that he
posted so there's a little guy with his
dad those pearls are just crazy and
blonde yeah and they also posted a photo
with Donna's mom Sophie bro so and this
is what Drake wrote in the post what is
most important for you right now is to
connect to your own inner light trust
that you have all of the power within to
make this happen in order to do that
connect it to the people and things that
bring you a lot of joy when the mind
starts to move into overthinking or fear
shift your attention away to something
bright I love and miss my beautiful
family and friends and I can't wait for
the joyful day when we're all able to
reunite into this you know it is a time
this is a time when you realize the
priorities in your life and that's
family and I think this is the perfect
time to share it but the question is
should he have shared a photo of his two
year old son what are your thoughts on
that well it's interesting I mean when
we've had these conversations before
when celebrities like all of a sudden
does something relevant question why did
they suddenly do it we obviously know
what kind of you know state of mind what
kind of state of mind we're all in that
Drake you know decided to do this now
but it is still shocking because he is
still private even on his Instagram like
most of his photos are very curated
there for him just put up not just one
photo like I think it's five photos this
is six in total yeah of these photos in
total yes he knows that people are gonna
talk about it yeah but it's cool the
yeah he's he's showing that Bobby love
like he's been so private about this
like we didn't know we had to sign in
originally and of course it was the
whole thing of Pusha T revealing it and
Drake had to come up say something about
it so yeah so for him to embrace it in
this kind of time I think it would have
been like his his his statement his
message on his drone has so much more
impact because he put the photo of a son
he's just like me you know finding the
joy the joy that you have in your life
and I miss my family and friends because
I'm assuming I mean Drake i think drake
is still in toronto right now you know
he was self isolating
originally after he hung out with Tim
Durant then he found out yeah it's just
the positive it doesn't have proven 19
but I think he's still stopped isolating
like I don't think he's with this time I
think that's the whole message is the
fact that he's missing him and is
missing his family and we know he's had
problems with Sophie for many many years
and for him to put a photo of her as
well yeah been him and his signing he
put up a picture of the mom as well and
he talks about letting the past go and I
think this is a message of saying moving
on things are getting better you know
one of the things and again you talked
about Pusha T making him do it maybe we
should actually give him apply push a TV
because acknowledge it and you know
there was also uh footage many many
years ago I think maybe it was last year
the year before where he talked about
the DNA testing and you know he needed
proof and now I kind of get an idea why
because his son looks just like his mom
but not like him right I know that's not
everyone say I mean it doesn't look like
anything like Drake yeah but then you
see yeah his mom that yeah like I mean
you said yeah you saw her with that kind
of blonde like pearl perm right yeah
when I met her she had this type perm I
guess this was 15 years ago and the
minute I saw the photo of his son I was
like yep that that looks just like his
mom and the blue eyes and so we forget
that he is mixed and I think that the
thing that that had an issue with this
morning was the way people responded
he's a two year old boy and there's been
some negativity out there and I think
this is not the right time and this was
a good time for Drake to come out and
talk about something that he never has
really acknowledged so I don't like the
idea of people being so negative but I
think there was a reaction this morning
to actually seeing photos of his son
yeah they think he probably knew that
was gonna be the case
anyways I mean yeah I have friends mind
that they're both you know black hair I
completely kind of darker features and
yeah their kid is a complete ginger yeah
grandfather is Scottish and a little bit
gingery so yeah that happened sometimes
for those kind of looks skip a
generation so I mean yeah I'm sure it
surprise you a lot this morning that he
has this kid that's those very light
complexion and yes blog
hi Zuri you know what his messaging was
great I'm glad he shared it I don't know
Keisha kept it private maybe because
he's a private person people didn't
expect him to share photos of his son
maybe he should have just kept it
private but the reasoning behind it I
don't know why did he do it I don't know
but good for him and I'm happy that he's
done it and he really does have a son